yeah that movies pretty heavy Deepwater
Horizon so Deepwater Horizon is a biopic
directed by Peter Berg Peter Berg he's
pretty hit or miss with me this movie
takes place onboard the Deepwater
Horizon and back in 2010 you remember
the Deepwater Horizon oil rig explodes
kills some people it was and remains the
biggest oil disaster in US history first
of all I heard that Mark Wahlberg may or
may not be up for an Oscar for this
movie I mean you hear that all the ties
Oscar seasons coming up as so-and-so is
going for an Oscar so-and-so is going
for an Oscar someone so it's rumored for
an Oscar and then you watch the movie
you're like yeah Mark Wahlberg was
really good Mark Wahlberg is our
everyday Joe he's our normal guy he's a
good dude he goes on deepwater horizon
then this happens and now he's that he
needs to get out of that situation and
needs to help people out of it I loved
him I loved Kurt Russell Kurt Russell's
in this movie and Kurt Russell was also
really good I just love his Kurt Russell
ish attitude now cookie there Bob we're
gonna test the cement hell's coming with
me you hear hell's coming with me I love
that dude and John Ditka fetch I mean
Malkovich but in this movie let's be
fair he's dick of it if that dude
actually acted like John Malkovich
betrayed him dude as some explaining to
do she's probably already done but this
movie does a great job at roping you in
it engrosses you you immediately attach
to Mark Wahlberg not only that but they
do a brilliant representation been
talking to it usually movies when they
break something down like this I'm
usually like yeah they're doing that for
the audience I did that in this one but
right here I was like that was
brilliantly done to illustrate to anyone
watching this movie of all ages exactly
what happened on deepwater horizon
visual aid with a soda can honey and a
straw and it's great it was big news we
knew it was a bad thing we knew it was
tragic people died but you don't really
grasp the magnitude of the situation but
you see it on the news you're like oh
it's on fire and that's really bad no
it's just not just on fire when this
stuff starts erupting and exploding you
don't even know how anyone lived through
this thing it's a miracle
looks like putting an m-80 in a milk jug
and lighting it off that's pretty much
Deepwater Horizon and it did a great job
at breaking down all the steps that
failed and led to the next step it's
just a stack of Domino situational
circum
Stan's knocking over the next one that
happened that failed that failed that
failed that failed that failed that
failed which that bellwood made that
bell all of it is sequentially just
going down it's like watching the
Titanic sink and the Titanic has teeth
and it's exploding and trying to kill
you but really guys this movie hits a
very particular and specific bone is
there there are disaster movies out
there that come out quite often there
are tragedy movies that come out quite
often run for your life movies they come
out quite often but this kind of thing
it comes out once in a while with the
right kind of heart to the right kind of
lead guy and unfathomably big disaster
that is going down around all these
people and the fact is it's real only
happened six short years ago it's not
too far back seriously it's the perfect
time to do this movie it's far enough to
where you can make a movie about it but
it's recent enough to remember what
happened I will say this way this is the
most impactful movie that I've seen in
2016 I walked out of this movie felt
like I was getting gut punch I just
walked out in silence no one was talking
when they were leaving they're like [ __ ]
that's it was just heavy ting people
scramble for their lives trying to
survive this unwinnable situation just
it's a big thing actually when that
happened and you remember the event this
is one of my favorite movies of the year
I'm not gonna lie to you guys if there's
a flaw I all say the lead-up leading to
the disaster took a little while but
it's well spent and necessary setup
because you don't want to just be like
oh cool this is remove you want to do it
with respect I'll say Deepwater Horizon
work for me and Deepwater Horizon is
awesome tacular
all right guys so Deepwater Horizon have
you seen it what did you think about it
what's the most intense biopic you have
seen thus far whatever it is whatever
you think comment below let me know and
as always if you like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]